hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
Emmanuel Kant begins his preface to his
short but very dense work prolongina to
any future metaphysics by telling us the
readers who he actually has in mind for
his intended audience and there are a
few things he the very first sentence
these prologulminar are not for the use
of pupils or students but of future
teachers and he goes on and talks about
Scholars For Whom the history of
philosophy is philosophy itself or their
philosophy and he says I'm not writing
it for them so who is he actually
intending in the present not just future
teachers down the line well he has an
intended audience there's an aim a goal
to this
opseeked an intention those who think
that metaphysics is worth
studying rough translation of Zeke
metaphysics
to occupy themselves with metaphysics
those who find this valuable and so
there's already a well-established
philosophical discipline of metaphysics
by the time that Kant is engaging in
this and writing his earlier work the
critique of pure reason that this is a
you know in some respect a prologomina
two
um but Kat thinks that there are
problems
with the existing metaphysics that we're
going to get to in just a moment so he
is going to talk about metaphysics as a
science a vision shaft so some sort of
body of knowledge that we can you know
say is genuine uh knowledge cognition of
its objects and Kant is writing at a
time during the you know mid-modern
period where the science is or at least
whatever we want to consider to be
Sciences have actually been making a
good bit of progress
so the question that he wants to raise
is is this happening with this
particular
science metaphysics and he's going to
tell us something that's actually quite
extraordinary
metaphysics doesn't actually exist as a
science at this point in time he he says
a little bit later that there has never
been done that there is as yet no such
thing as metaphysics so if we understand
metaphysics to be things that are in in
books of metaphysics or taught in
metaphysics classes or ideas that people
have in their head sure there's there's
metaphysics there's plenty of it none of
that is genuine metaphysics as a real
science however so Kant is criticizing
the metaphysics that is presented as
being
here in in his time in previous times as
well the history of philosophy
he does say though that the human mind
or specifically reason fair enough
um demands that metaphysics be developed
exist right he says it can never cease
to be in demand
um needed desired why because he says
the interests
of human reason in general are
intimately interwoven with it so why
does a non-scientific
mishmash discipline of metaphysics
exists because we can't do without it
and
um people using human reason have been
developing theories and ideas and
throwing them around for really
Millennia now Kant says that what's
really needed is a radical footage in
German so a thorough going
reform or rebirth
uh of this this discipline and so you
know a rebirth that's kind of an
interesting idea uh annoyager right so a
new birth because it's never really been
born or a reform that goes down to the
very Roots if we want to use the term
radical and Kant thinks that he is going
to offer that and that will be as he
articulates it here he says the
independent reader of these prologomina
will not only doubt his previous science
but will be fully persuaded it cannot
exist unless the demands the food around
here stated on which its possibility
depends uh be satisfied and Kant is the
one who is going to be articulating
these now jumping back a little bit
earlier in the preface
he's going to raise some problems
this is why he thinks that metaphysics
is not at this point in time a real
science
uh one of the Criterion is that there's
no Universal no agamina and Lasting
daruna recognition by fall of it as a
science or of the achievements uh that
have been attained up until this point
he says well this is a little weird
because if we look at other Sciences so
think about chemistry for example people
carry out experiments come up with all
sorts of theories that go far beyond the
experiment and sometimes you have to do
with things that cannot be directly
observed they talk about it at a certain
point people are like yeah okay this is
what we think as chemists or as
physicists or as biologists it starts
getting a little bit stickier there and
as we get into the social sciences or
into history
maybe it's not quite so easy to say but
there should at least be some consensus
developing right and the consensus
should stick so to speak and Khan says
look at metaphysics
that hasn't happened so what's the deal
there he says all the other Sciences
make advances uh foot root right they
proceed from one problem one issue to
another and what they leave behind is
viewed as secures having been
established whereas with metaphysics
everybody's doing their own thing so to
speak or they're following along
somebody else's path and he says whether
we demonstrate our knowledge or our
ignorance in this field we must come
once and for all to a definite
conclusion respecting the nature of this
so-called science which cannot possibly
remain on its present footing it seems
ridiculous laughable right that all
these other Sciences are advancing and
this one that pretends to be wisdom
incarnate uh we should constantly move
around the same spot without gaining a
single step and this leads to people
being rather leery of engaging in
metaphysics they're like yeah I don't
know about that maybe you you people who
aren't good at the other Sciences do
this this is you know the same kind of
critique that we see people making from
the uh you know we could call it the
basis of stem not real stem work but you
know sort of a an ideal of it against
philosophy in general isn't it and other
things now he goes on and he says one of
the big problems with this is that we we
don't have some sort of
um
standard
zikrus so zikrus means secure right so
standard works there
um weight and measure to distinguish to
to make a separation between uh
soundness from shallow talk so we don't
have a Criterion by which we can tell
real metaphysics if that indeed exists
from all the silly spun out stuff that
people have been generating year after
year after year so these are some
significant problems if indeed true and
con certainly takes them to be true and
there's you know good reason for this
so what does this lead us to well Kant
not only has a set of problems but he
has what he would like to offer us as a
solution
and this Begins by asking a key question
how such a science is actually possible
how it would be possible that's in the
subjunctive right and so he says that
this is now the time to ask this and
it's okay to do that we do have a lot of
metaphysics on the scene but he says
there's nothing extraordinary in the
elaboration of a science when men begin
to wonder how far is it Advanced that
the question should at last occur
whether and how in general such a
science is possible human reasons so
Delights and constructions that it is
several times built up a tower and then
raised it destroyed it pulled it down to
examine the nature of the foundation
it's never too late to become reasonable
and wise but it's going to be a little
bit difficult because there's already
people doing metaphysics out there and
they are not going to like this he says
he says this raises doubts and a doubt
offends the man whose entire our Goods
May consist in the supposed Jewel so you
must expect opposition from all sides
that's what content fact expects but he
says that this question whether a
science be possible
presupposes or sets out
uh a doubt advice a wavering between
Alternatives about now notice this term
it's actuality it's vehicle kite is the
stuff that's out there as metaphysics
presenting itself actually in reality
vehicle
metaphysics or not does it meet up with
its
promise does it fulfill its you know I
what what it is actually preferring to
people a knowledge of reality Kant is
saying
no it hasn't done that we need to ask a
fundamental question
and in doing so we actually make a path
for a future metaphysics that would in
fact be adequate that should command
Universal and Lasting recognition so
that is where the prologomina begins in
the very early pages of the preface
setting a stage for us setting a central
problem for the rest of the work